You're listening to radio lab from New York public radio public radio,
W Y Y C Huh.
And
uh,
ah, [inaudible] live at the Fitzgerald Theater in Saint Paul, Minnesota.
October 30th, 1938.
On that night,
the United States experienced a kind of mass hysteria the we'd never seen
before.
And the reason which today sounds almost comical was a radio play
really. I did spoken with them.
Orson wells and the mercury set are on the air and the water of the world
around 12 million people were listening. Most got the joke.
It was Halloween after all.
But if you consider that about one out of every 12 people didn't get the joke.
That's what surveys found afterwards about one out of every 12 people who heard
the broadcast thought it was true and that some percentage of that 1 million
people ran out of their homes, towels over their faces, clutching children,
tripping, breaking limbs will,
that constitutes the major freak out and in the Sur first ever live hour on
radio lab here at Saint Paul, Minnesota at the Fitzgerald Theater, we ask why,
why do people panic? And of course we'll ask the big question as well,
which is Canaan happened again.
I'm Jad Abumrad thank you all for coming in.
Where's my coding much?
So let me,
let me just say at the outset, I'm just a tiny bit puzzled. Did you tell it,
tell everyone who you are. Oh, I, yeah, I'm Robert.
Can you just say Robert Crawl, which is my name. And uh, uh,
with all due respect,
I mean if we had any number of things we could done in the hour,
we could have done sex lives of watermelons or something interesting about
chrysanthemums.
I don't know why choose a Martian invasion radio show from 1938 old old,
old. I'm thinking, I can't believe you wait till now to ask me question. I know.
I'm just thinking. So some of them might be thinking, you know, old, old,
no, you don't gay. Well I guess it's a valid question you ask. Truth is,
I actually only discovered the war of the world recently in 2001 kind of late
2001 actually not long after that day in 2001 and it just really struck me and
it wasn't so much that the broadcast had a kind of end of the World Nis that I
guess we were all feeling in real life at that moment,
but it was more just the way that the story unfolded step by step by step and
how in the broadcast you feel like you were lost inside a newscast,
which is not unlike what it was like. Yeah, we were all, you know,
glued to the TV and real life grasping at these pieces of news,
trying to figure out what was going on. And that was very much,
I think what they were trying to create in the broadcast. But now,
many years later, what I'm really left with is a question, what?
Well,
if I were alive in 1938 in front of the radio and I heard this sounds,
what would I have thought would I have believed it would have not believed?
I mean, I don't know. What about you? I don't really know. I don't really know.
I Dunno. Okay, well let's do something. Just start us off here.
Let's actually go back to 1938 and see if we can figure out how these sounds
landed on people's ears and what information they had in their heads. So,
and I need your help with this. How would I help with that? Yeah, you,
I want you to go over to that seat right there. That's,
we're going to call that seat in 1938 all right. There Nike. Okay.
Now just, let's just all imagine there you are on your easy chair.
You're maybe drinking a cream soda.
Let's tune the dial.
Okay. Were you always trying to find something here?
[inaudible]
okay, I've got something on the dial
in the Park Plaza Hotel in New York today we bring you the
Munich Raymond ruck kilo. Who is Rick
marginal or Raymond Rock? Hello.
The doctors,
the Fetish Raymont Rick Yellow lead off with lower carpentry de [inaudible].
Nope.
You don't know that there's no such person is removed. Rick. Hello.
And it's just a record and a CBS studio, but it sounds professional enough.
So you sit back, you relax. But then later go,
we don't
[inaudible].
So at this point you think I'm thinking explosions on Mars,
hydrogen gas moving towards earth. A little strange.
But how could it be so bad if I still get to listen to the fabulous notes at the
lovely Raymond Keller and he does continue to play for another minute,
34 seconds. But then it happens again.
Ladies and gentlemen, following on the newest,
given an off bullet in the moment of golf,
the governor's media rheological bureau has requested the log.
Hello. Now before we go ahead and leave it there for, are we going any further?
Let me ask a really basic question here. I mean, we're dealing with a play,
a radio play. Yeah.
Why would Orson wells and his posse of have troubadours start their play this
way?
The original h g well story was written in 1898 so it was really an old book at
the time. And there, there is no reporter character in the book. By the way,
does everybody know this war of the world story or most people do?
The story basically is this little green creatures from Mars for a number of
reasons having to do with thirst or something,
have to leave their planet and they come to Earth. They're not very nice people.
They invade, they destroy quite a number of us.
And then ironically in the end they get killed by little viruses,
our smallest inhabitants of our planet, bite them and destroy them.
And it science fiction of course. But in 1938 most kids knew this story.
It was very popular. So I don't see why.
Right? And in fact,
let me bring in a clip from a Orson wells producer at the time, John Houseman,
uh, Austin and I chose it. We decided the time had come,
we should be doing a science fiction show. And so we tried a few of that.
One very easy to do in just a few days before they had to be on the air with
their next installment,
John Houseman pools that book off the shelf to shows it to o w says, Hey,
what about this in Orson Welles says, yes,
you want me to do this?
Well, he had trouble in what sense? In the sense of the design,
you said it was no, no. He said it was boring.
Uh, if it was something that happened 50 years ago,
everybody knows it didn't happen. So, uh, who the health care, right?
If we're gonna make people care about this old story,
we've got updated not 1898, 1938.
And it just so happened that one month prior,
something had happened that forever changed the world in the news.
What was that? We'll begin with the story.
The
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Hitler was threatening Europe first, Austria,
then Czechoslovakia World War Two was right around the corner and CBS sent a
team of guys to cover this story among them.
Allambia continues or six events with [inaudible] European [inaudible]
and in September morrow and his CBS producers did something with the news that
was kind of novel. They broke in,
we interrupt this program of music by Howard Jameson,
this orchestra who bring you a bullet in just received and the w o r and he was
wrong.
Now this had happened before, but never quite like this with live reports,
eye witness account, and never quite so much
square up their broadcast. Bring it up in Portland, probably at night of prep
in just one month. These bulletins have become so numerous.
We interrupt our program to bring a special broadcast.
That bulletins were practically interrupting both.
We interrupt this program to bring you a special broadcast.
We interrupt this broadcast to bring it as important. You, me from the United
leading up this program to take you to the NBC News Room. Yeah,
it's a special of it on the end.
So after weeks and weeks of hearing these constant interruptions,
it's easy to understand why this [inaudible] gentleman
following on you. It's given an awful lot in the moment of golf.
Didn't sound like a play. Okay.
The guy rolled out the there all has requested the [inaudible] of the country,
the cap on astronomical board on any part of it that Starbucks are calling on
the planet. We have arranged an interview with another, this product,
my professor parents, I'm going to give out
[inaudible] Jersey. We're not talking about a pedal then with the Keller pillow,
the door.
I don't know whether I need it anymore. Raymond Martello.
I need to know a little more about this Martian. Uh,
isn't it interesting how slowly it starts? And by the way,
what time do you get on your, uh, your a pocket watch there?
The pocket watch says eight Oh four eight oh four.
Tell me when it gets to eight oh five to what?
805-EIGHT-OH-5805.
You know, just let me know and no. OK. It'll five.
This is my favorite minute in understanding one of the greatest media hoaxes of
all times.
Cause the thing that's interesting is that at this moment in October of 1938,
Orson wells in the mercury theater of the air were not that popular.
They had a tiny, tiny slice of the audience.
And so not too many people were listening. Certainly not at the beginning,
from eight o'clock to eight oh four and so not too many people heard this very
important introduction,
the Columbia Broadcasting System and its affiliated stations.
Was that the war of the world by h g? Well,
well why wait, why didn't they hear that? Well, cause at that very same moment,
the majority of people listening were tuned into this
[inaudible]
the makers of Jason Sanborn copied is the power of Glam, you know, is fresh.
Resent the chase and Sandborne out,
um, that chase in sandbourne hours. Now that that was good.
That was Edberg and it had the puppet
Charlie McCarthy Mu who liked girls. It was rainy.
It was the most popular show at the time, right opposite the murder.
Every theater of the year had 10 times the audience.
But at eight oh five host Donald beachy introduces and not so popular singer.
And it's the rousing rip roaring song. The vagabonds from the Vagabond J
oh your mega la [inaudible] de la.
And yes, at that moment, thousands. Hundreds.
We don't know how many listeners started to dial. Sir.
Where are they landed on the mercury theater of the air already in progress
where they stayed.
We already know how to take you to the principle observatory at Princeton
because by then a strange meteor had landed
where Carl Phillips,
our commentator will interview with Professor Richard Pearson,
famous astronomer. That's it. The IB cannot questions at any time.
It's about the no piping
BIM status.
Excellent. That's kind of the tough one.
I just remembered in the other one.
Yeah, we've had four interruptions. Now at this point,
you've called your whole family into the room,
Marge meteor's on immediately on Mars March, meteors,
y meteors on Mars,
and just as you are utterly confused, along comes the expert, you know,
people surveyed afterwards said, I didn't believe this thing.
I thought it was all baloney until I heard that government official guy or the a
Princeton professor, and this script is chocked full of believable experts.
Right? Or the Natural History Museum,
Professor [inaudible] of the California Astronomical Society,
their General Montgomery Smith, Captain Lansing of the signal card.
Maybe subconsciously that had an effect to convince people that something was in
fact happening.
A feeling furthered a moment later when the professor and, uh,
the reporter Carl Phillips, go live to that field in Grovers mill,
New Jersey with that media, right, or whatever it is. It's Atlantic.
Hang on one sec. I'm gonna Start. Hi
Papa.
[inaudible].
Her mouth is, that's kind of the shape.
What's the lie that's dripping on equipment? I hate rimless lips actually,
as do I. Now, before we get too far into this, see,
let me play you a another clip,
right? You're providing majestically Florida like them. Great. Better. Yeah.
There's no doubt.
Recognize this. See this. Listen a little bit more.
Lining the windows, looking down the road ahead of them.
Get a shot to get this cottage. It's fine. Edit pricing. Oh my.
Get out of the way please.
If running and bursting into flames and it's falling on the mornings,
I have to tell him all the humanity at all. The presenters,
Freebie Garages,
this is tape of the Hindenburg crash. It's still fresh in people's minds.
Happened one year before the broadcasts,
before going on the air that night after Frank Redick who played that reporter
call Phillips in the field, he went to the library,
dug up this old tape or not so old and played it to himself.
Oh, the Humana did all that. [inaudible] oh,
the your manna did all the feathers. [inaudible] oh,
the humanity and all the predators
get himself in the right frame of mind for that now famous attack scene in that
field and New Jersey.
Those pitches know what that means about anything mean. Wait a minute,
something happening.
This rising out of the pit and then they got a small beam of light against the
mirror. What's that? Yeah,
the flame springs in the mirror. At least try to do that.
[inaudible]
the transmission cuts off.
12 million people have just heard slithery green aliens.
He visceral policemen, farmers and reporters followed by
nothing. Why does it go to circumstances beyond our control?
We are going to continue to broadcast from
[inaudible] transmission. However,
we really return to that point at the earliest opportunity
and when they do return,
what you learn is that that grounded flying saucer that just zapped all those
men has now stood up. It's grown legs,
it's as tall as a tree and it is marching
[inaudible]
through the countryside,
stopping everything in its path and then we are taken to field reports,
live battle scenes between militia and positive. Before we do,
let me play one more clip. This one is real
and one of the areas you mentioned the type of child of school age and wished to
have an evacuated.
You should send him to school tomorrow Friday with hand luggage containing the
child gas mask or a change of underclothing.
This is Edward r Murrow reporting from London. Same time period.
Just to give you a sense of how scary it was to be alive at this moment in time,
kids in England were being told to take gas masks to school,
all of which would've made the following dramatize battle scenes.
They do now for the field headquarter, the Mulatto, there's robotic mill,
New Jersey,
all the more wheels.
31 me to do. You want me to come? 37 degree.
We've got to do fire
here. The New Jersey militia fire on a fleet of marsh and pods
to no avail.
Their sales bounce right off in the margins in retaliation,
release a cloud or poisonous gas
which slowly overtake the soldiers.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
ladies and gentlemen, I have a grave enough announcement to make incredible.
Come on please ladies and gentlemen. Now another boat from Langland field,
Virginia amongst it is now in control of the Middle Section of New Jersey and
has effectively cut the state through its center highways to the north, south,
and West. The clog with frantic human triathletes.
Nami reserves are unable to control the MED flight communication lines that down
from Pennsylvania to the let go.
A tone in service discontinued except bachelor prevail throughout New Jersey and
eastern Pennsylvania. Cutting planes report enemy machines.
Now three a number increasing speed northbound kicking over houses and every
time we take you to Washington for the sons of a nation,
the secretary of the interior, I shall not try to conceal the gravity bullet.
It handed me away from the box. Paul ain't going on
with the customer at the end. Now, no more defense.
Everything wiped out.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we don't know exactly how many people panic that night. Here's what we do now.
The Trenton Police Department got 2000 calls in under two hours.
The New York Times switchboard received 875 calls alone from people wanting to
know where they'd be safer
on the roof or in the gas rate shelter in a cellar.
We are lucky.
We do have transcripts of what happened on the other side of radios that night.
Thanks to a Princeton sociologist who went out and conducted a series of
interviews after the broadcast and what's amazing is how effective that
broadcast was.
Some listeners said they actually felt like they were choking.
Others reported to police that they saw with their own eyes as they looked at
the Manhattan skyline.
They saw a thin veil of smoke from the battle over the city.
Some said they saw Martian machines high,
stepping their way down the palisade splash, splash, splash,
and many people when they called operators or police, they didn't say,
oh my God, we're being invaded by Martians. They said, oh my God,
we're being invaded by Germans.
Here are some of the literal transcriptions is what real people
actually say, right,
buddy? Ready? I knew it was some Germans trying to gas us all,
but when the announcer kept on calling them people from Mars,
I just thought he was ignorant.
I immediately called up the Maplewood police and asked if there was anything
wrong. They answer. We know as much as you do.
Keep your radio tuned in and follow the announcer's advice.
Yeah, I called into my husband, Dan, why don't you get dressed?
You don't want to die in your working clothes.
I looked in icebox and saw some chicken left from Sunday dinner that I was
saving for Monday night dinner. I said to my nephew,
we may as well eat this chicken. We won't be here in the morning.
This is Dalton wealth. Ladies and gentlemen, out of character,
we'll show you that the war of the world has no further significant and at the
holiday offering it was intended to be.
We annihilated the world before your very ears and utterly destroyed the CBS.
You will be relieved. I hope,
to learn that we didn't mean it and that both institutions are still open for
business.
That was that Orson wells concluded the war.
The world's broadcast with those words basically. Huh? Was a joke.
Gotcha. But it was only after he and his producer, Jon,
has been left and read the papers the next day and they understood just how much
trouble they had caused [inaudible] disagreeable because of for at least a
couple of hours. We believe we were mass murder.
Extremely surprised to learn that a story which is become familiar to children
through the medium of comic strips and a
this as well as in the press conference that following day,
mini succeeding novels and adventure stories should have had such an immediate
and profound effect upon radio listeners.
So immediate and so profound that the FCC Commissioner of the time,
George Henry Payne labeled the Mercury theater of the air,
get this terrorists
[inaudible]
radio terrorists.
But there is one thing we must not overlap all this took place in 1938 and our
less sophisticated yesterday that did not know the atom bomb guided missiles and
rockets that may shortly fly to the Moon Edward
r Murrow in 1957. Was he correct when he said that?
Where are we really so on sophisticated in 1938. I mean,
it's so different from now.
Well, let's see. Huh?
Stay with US folks. I'm Robert Krulwich and Jana and Ron.
We're alive at the Fitzgerald Theater in Saint Paul,
Minnesota radio lab will continue
just a moment.
Radiolab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public and the National Science Foundation
radio lab is produced by Wny C and distributed by n p. R.
We interrupt this broadcast for some breaking news. This Justin,
it seems we may have gotten a few things wrong when we, uh,
perform that show many years ago.
Most notably just now when I said that the FCC,
a commissioner in 1938 called Orson Welles radio terrorists in his statement,
he certainly suggests that, but if you read it,
it seems he was actually referring to a statement he made about a year earlier
where he was calling radio producers who terrorized children.
He doesn't actually name Orson Welles by name. I just botched that.
My apologies. And we have this guy to thank for bringing it to our attention.
Michael Sokolow and I'm associate professor of journalism and communication at
the University of Maine.
And uh,
Michael Sokolow also makes an interesting argument that the panic may not have
been as large as we made it sound. For example, uh, we stayed,
the 12 million people were listening on that night,
which is a widely quoted number and it comes from polling done six weeks after
the war.
The world's first aired Sokoloff suspects that the actual number of listeners is
way smaller and there's no way to know for sure, but he trusts a poll conducted
that night.
That night when the broadcast was on 5,000 Americans were surveyed by the CE
Hooper Company, the rating survey company.
Why are we bothering with a study done six weeks later after the newspaper tells
everybody that there was this giant panic?
Why don't we look at the surveys that were done that night and the survey that
was done 12 hours later by cvs the following morning? What are the two surveys?
Immediately after,
say the CE Hooper rating survey found 98% of the respondents were not listening
to Orson wells or war of the worlds.
They were listening to the chase in Sanborn hour or their radios were off or
they were listening to another program of the 2% that they found that were
listening to war of the world.
Not a single respondent thought it was a phony news broadcast.
Sokolow strongly suspects that the panic was actually trumped up by the
newspapers who were trying to sort of piss on this new medium called radio that
was taken away their, you know, audience.
Exactly. Here was the opportunity and a radio.
The radio industry and the newspaper industry had been battling for years.
And throughout that decade, the entire newspaper industry had been losing money,
political prestige and other things to the radio industry. You know,
some of their best employees.
And so they were waiting for a way to really prove to advertisers and prove to
federal regulators, you know, they had the first amendment,
they understood responsibility. These are the newspaper managers.
These radio guys were conflating advertising with programming.
They were frightening their viewers. They were acting irresponsibly.
And remember,
this is a month after Munich when radio proved that news really works on the
radio. Well, one month after radio news, you know, comes of age,
suddenly they're conflating news accounts with and they're acting irresponsibly
and they're terrorizing the public.
And so the newspaper industry had the perfect thing to hang their critique of
radio on.
Interesting. And that's interesting. So all those,
all those eye witness accounts that the panic and I thought it was this and I
packed my bags and whatever, whatever.
And all this sort of reports of people miscarrying.
Do you feel like that's all in memory embellished or what?
How do you explain that?
Well, let me give you, let me give you an analogy. Okay.
If you were to ask 100 Americans today,
did you see a plane fly into the World Trade Center on September 11th I think
you would get an extremely high percentage of people saying they saw that plane
fly in. But that's because it's part of our national visual memory.
It's really a trauma and it's, it's,
it's the kind of hysteria and panic we're talking about.
So that moment in time and our relationship to the media. Okay.
But if you were to actually find out who's TVs were on live at nine 48 in the
morning that day and who was actually watching,
there would be a discrepancy in that number. Now,
am I saying all those people are lying? All those people are confused. No.
What I'm saying is that the relationship of memory to the media is extremely
complex,
complex indeed,
and we think Michael Sokolov for checking our facts and if you believe as he
does, the 1938 panic was,
well it didn't happen or it wasn't as bad as it sounds then that actually makes
what we talked about next in our live broadcast, even more puzzling.
So let's get back to that. This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. We are in Saint Paul, Minnesota.
Coming to you live from the Fitzgerald Theater.
Our subject today is the war of the worlds broadcast.
Originally on October 30th, 1938
okay, now I'm gonna ask the house for a show of hands.
The question for the house is,
do you think that somebody else could imagine the broadcast using the exact same
script more or less? Also with Martians also invading,
also interrupting the musical things.
Same deal after all the publicity from the 1938 broadcast.
Could you do it twice? Show of hands, please. Oh,
some of you don't think so. Look if we, if,
if there wasn't another one of these,
what would we be doing for the next 40 minutes?
So those of you who've raised your hands, let's say it's about 75% of you,
you are correct because it has happened again. And I want to tell you a story.
It's an amazing story, really.
An underreported story of a war of the worlds reenactment happened in the
mountains of Quito, Ecuador in 1949 we were very lucky.
We had a reporter, Tony Fields, who happened to be traveling there.
We asked them to do a couple of interviews for people who heard it or were
there, and he brought back some tape and played it for me in studio. All right,
so Tony set the scene for me. 1949 Quito. Where's Quito?
Quito is the capital of Ecuador.
Iquitos in the middle of the mountains in the Andes mountains and small town,
big town. Quito. Now is a big city. At the time it was a pretty small city.
It had a quarter of a million people, you know, 300,000 tops. Um,
the word that everybody who I spoke to use to describe the way that Quito was in
1949 was trying Hilo
[inaudible] and I want to see that [inaudible] like tranquil. Exactly.
It is what it sounds like. Tranquil, calm, chill,
and Radio Quito was the most popular radio station.
Everybody was into it.
So those are your basic ingredients. You get a small town population,
250,000. You have one major radio station,
which also happened to be in the same building as the one major newspaper,
El Comercio and the leader of the radio station. The guy who ran it,
a devious fellow by the name of Leonardo Pius,
one day someone shows up with a script for Orson wells, not HD wills.
Orson Welles version of war of the worlds, gives it a Leonardo pious. He reads,
it says, brilliant, we've got to do this.
Hue and Quito ban certain local place names, you know.
So instead of the Martians landing in New Jersey,
they would land and cut the [inaudible], which is on the outskirts of Quito.
They write in parts for government officials, the minister of the interior.
The mayor of Tito is there. Actors are real government.
These would be factors doing impressions, doing impressions. That's right.
Not only that, pious got his bosses at the newspaper,
El Comercio to agree to run little articles in the newspaper in the two days
leading up to the broadcast reporting.
That strange objects had been seen in a sky's over Keith though.
Wow.
So he set out to screw with people basically. I mean he was planting paranoia.
It really seems like he wanted people to believe what they were hearing that
night.
Okay.
Okay, so Saturday, February 12th, 1949 the day of the broadcast,
all day long listeners here and announcement windows niches and you'll notice a
notice that there's going to be a special performance. It's like a duo,
Benitez Valencia. They need this.
Valencia Valencia at that time were one of the most popular musical acts in town
in Gladio. Quito. Why don't you cue up a track number for [inaudible]
[inaudible]
eight o'clock rolls around Beneatha's Valencia launches into their performance.
They play a few songs
[inaudible]
and suddenly there's an interruption.
Some sort of strange kind of interference like sound.
What do you mean? Like static, static, a signals,
you know something's wrong with it. It's not coming in quite right. Wait,
what was that? Well, it turns out that Leonardo,
the pies in addition to the other tricks they had up his sleeve,
he had a salad effects guy in the corner that was creating this sounded like
[inaudible]
like when it garrison Keillor's guys kind of a thing.
That's right, Tom. Keith. Everyone.
Eventually the music stops and Leonardo Paez comes on the air and says
[inaudible] please dear listeners, excuse the technical difficulties.
There seems to be some sort of atmosphere conditions interfering with the radio.
Keep those signal. But you are the thing to radio ketosis brought to you by,
you know, such and such. And now back to this balance here.
There's balance here.
[inaudible]
so we hear another couple of songs and then there's another interruption up in
soon. It's laying out to the payers again. And this time,
this time it's a news flash. So now we're on script. That's right. That's right.
They send pyres out to report from the scene and pies is doing the play by play.
You know, what is it? Hang on my God, the tops on school, you know,
come the clinicals
and here come the heat. Rise and Zap.
Hi, is this fry?
You can wait, wait, wait, wait. Do we have forget reenactments?
Do we have a copy of that? The real broadcast from that night,
all we have are descriptions.
There is no existing recording of what was broadcast that night and,
and you'll understand why in a second.
So while I was down there in Quito,
I interviewed a bunch of people about what happened that night.
By all accounts at work
outside,
it was here may everything that happened next happened extremely quickly.
People pull it out into the streets.
People were running but they didn't know where to run.
The spaceship supposedly was in the north of the city,
but there's black cloud of gas was in the south and a lot of them actually did
what any good Catholic would do.
They made a beeline for the church,
the church, because, because they were,
they thought they'd be safe there or perhaps,
or perhaps they just wanted to get right with God before the world ended there.
Even reports, and I wasn't able to confirm this,
but there were reports of men confessing to adultery right there in front of
their wives and priests. Absolving whole crowds at once.
Queue up a track track. 10
[inaudible] [inaudible] was [inaudible]. This is Jorge [inaudible],
who was a longtime journalist, worked for many years at the newspaper.
He was listening with his family. They all believed it. They all ran outside,
found a taxi cab to the kids in the rest of them ran behind the taxi cab.
They were going to [inaudible] the city, you Glen
[inaudible] and he tells that he sees going the other way. You buy this convoy.
Okay.
Military trucks filled with soldiers. Do we? Real trucks,
real military fans,
real military vans with the real soldiers and cops behind them and they're
screaming towards the north of the city. Where are they going?
They're going to cut the cord [inaudible] to fight the Martians. Yeah. No.
So if you, if you had any
doubt at this point that this was a, well maybe it's, maybe it's real.
Maybe it's not. Once you saw this military advance, you were like, oh, bleep,
I've got to get the hell out. Right. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I believe that does, does everybody in Quito believe like the army beat?
Didn't someone call the general beforehand?
Say Tonight we're having a broad day. The mayor or someone who sounded an awful,
like the mayor was on the radio saying Martians were invading.
And so if you're the army guy,
you're going to go check it out or you have to protect.
But the mayor didn't call the general before a no, no. So,
so then what happens at the end of the show,
assuming it ends with the way they always do as Omaha judge, then what?
Well, they stormed the radio station.
Let's go ahead. By the time it broadcast ended and it was announced,
but the whole thing was a play.
A huge crowds were in the streets and word that it was a hoax spread pretty
quickly. All that fear turned pretty quickly to anger.
[inaudible]
by nine 30 is these a few hundred people outside the station?
At some point there's boxer shows out there just been a match in the Central
Plaza and the boxer shows up and he's driving this truck and the truck is full
of rocks. These what? Rocks is full of rocks. Yeah.
And people start hurling. The rocks at the station,
at the windows and windows are shattering. They managed to break into the,
to the ground floor where the printing presses on.
They're smashing printing presses. At some point,
some people in the crowd materialize and they have these flaming torches and it
just goes up like a matched. So, so, so where people hurt during this
six people died. Oh really? Yeah, most escaped.
There was about 50 people in the building. Most got, uh, up to the roof,
jump to adjoining buildings. But six people died according to a reporter, Tony,
uh, one guy are stayed behind.
The last guy on the air that night was a man by the name of Louis Beltran.
Maria, are you there?
Yes, I'm here.
Okay. This is Maria Beltran. Testagrossa a Lewis Bill,
trans daughter and Maria, you are listening to,
to everything that just came before this. Yeah.
Tell us the story from Your Dad's perspective, uh, from here forward.
He was on the air. What was he doing?
Uh, well he was, he was on the air. He was the,
I guess hosting the music program and also doing some of the interruption with
the, uh, with the bogus. Uh,
but the point at the point in which the fire started, what was he saying?
Well, at that point when he realized the magnitude of situation,
he went back on the air and began pleading for help pleading for assistance from
the police and the fire department. But as you said before,
no help came because the police were going to fight the Morrison. Yeah.
And uh, eventually he was the last one left and uh,
and he jumped out the window.
I'd get from the either the third or fourth floor onto a second floor balcony.
And to break the fall, I guess it's [inaudible]. You want to break the fall?
He grabbed onto the railing of that balcony and he was completely engulfed in
flames at that point.
And the skin on his hands just remained on the balcony.
It was like a barbecue grill. And uh,
from there he jumped to the ground, but before he jumped,
he was pleading to the crowd to I guess catch him, but they didn't.
He landed on cement, uh, broke legs,
arm ribs, everything, and compounded by the very,
very serious burns that he had all over his body.
So he landed at the feet of an angry mob. What a,
an angry mob. And He, uh,
he recall that as he's losing consciousness, he just heard somebody say,
just let him die in peace. Although some of the articles that I read,
they try to throw him back into the building. Really. If someone, uh,
grabbed him and put him in a jeep to take him to the hospital, just a bystander.
And you know, he had so many scars here as children,
like my brother and I would, we'd play with his scars.
You would trace them with our finger and ask them what happened.
You know how we got the scars and he would tell us about the fire that,
you know, the building had burned and he would tell us about that.
What would he tell you the whole story or how much of this did you know?
Dory, he would just give us in just in broad terms,
but he had been in a building that caught fire. Uh, he also told us, you know,
he had been in a radio announcer, but, uh, as children we didn't really ask him.
Maybe had we been older and asked them, he would have told us the whole story.
Hmm.
And we should say that your dad stayed behind to try and help other people get
out of the building. Well, let me ask you a question though. Uh,
your dad obviously is a hero,
but given the fact that he was one of the voices that created the panic,
do you feel some sort of ambivalence about it?
Did he feel some sort of ambivalence about,
I don't know, in retrospect whether he did or not,
I'm sure they must have been some ambivalence. But from what I understand,
the story was kept,
it was very top secret so that even the employees did not know what was going to
be broadcast during that music program. Really though,
I don't know at what point he was informed of the detail.
So I don't know really how we felt about,
I wish I had had an opportunity to ask him.
Hmm. Well listen, Maria,
thank you so much for your time and joining us here and yeah, thanks. Perfect.
Okay.
Hi. Hi.
Want to know what happened to the guy who planned the whole,
uh, well he, uh, he got out through the roof like a lot of others.
He hopped to the next building, hit out for a few days,
and then fled the country to Venezuelan. Never to return,
never to return, never to return.
But I should say that among the six people who died that night was his
girlfriend and a nephew of his.
Okay. So the 1949 kito broadcast caused a whole lot of trouble.
The 1938 New York broadcast caused a whole lot of trouble.
Now everybody here before who raised their hand and thought that this could
happen again. You are right. Again,
Lao Buffalo, 1968
chapel
[inaudible] on the radio. Let me go to get it all together.
Between now and about midnight a little bit then after or whatever.
It's the height of the Vietnam war, Wk BW broadcast.
It's fascinating.
The version of the war of the worlds updated for the Times.
It sounds kind of like your basic DJ set until you hear this.
What is his Joe down and to be something here that I'm supposed to read.
Thank you. Thank you Joe. Uh, let's see. The NASA, NASA,
the national spacious and aeronautics administration.
Those people have alerted all their space watch and a facilities to be on the
alert for unusual communication difficulties tonight I suppose before the,
a federal agency referred to the explosions on the planet Mars and study was not
known if they would have the same effect on earth communications as similar
explosions on the surface of the sun.
I guess you're talking about sun spots and things like that. So, uh,
I don't know that shadow to it means that it's to be hard to hear communications
from national. I don't know.
Can you hear me? Daughter's South Carolina. Laura, you can hear kv whatevers.
You make it by communication.
[inaudible] y'all can you take what you're hearing on a week night,
getting it all together where it is? Will you pay me double? You remember WKBS
WWE broadcast followed the same structure as the original broadcast.
We've heard tonight long stretches of music than the news bulletins and the sent
me realistic field reports. Here's one of them.
What do you got?
You got walking injuries or real bad or you got the same vivid descriptions of
Martians. Hi, bike on. We all got it, Don. I got it. They all got it, Huh?
And according to the station manager, Jeff K, he gets the same outcome.
People bought it.
The Buffalo police and telephone company reported to Wk VW that they receive
more than 4,000 phone calls.
The Canadian military authorities dispatched military units to the Peace Bridge,
the Rainbow Bridge, and the Queenstown Bridge to repel invaders.
The story was carried the next day by 47 newspapers,
the country wide and on the night of the show and during the show,
you're not depressed bureaus up and down the east coast of America where a
besieged by phone calls asking about the Martian invasion in buffalo.
Incredible. You're absolutely right. It is incredible.
[inaudible] thanks to the folks at Wk BW
buffalo for that. What is this music, by the way?
This is the disco version of war of the worlds 1978
there's a discovery. It still sells a lot of copies. You'd be surprised.
Here's the obvious question to ask.
Why does this keep working? Oh, well that's a difficult question.
I came across a psychology professor. I'm Richard Gehrig.
I am a professor of psychology in the cognitive experimental program at Stony
Brook University.
He has this notion Richard Gehrig does and it rude people are suckers for
stories. We just cannot help ourselves. When a story starts,
you just kind of go, whoa.
I think the norm is to fall into the story and that it's unusual to sort of keep
yourself from falling it by. Favorite example is a,
there's a scene in gold finger.
Yeah. For the all time best James Bond movie. I think we're bond is tied down,
spread eagle on a piece of metal and there's this laser coming toward him,
which really looks like he's gonna cut them into.
And even as I'm saying that right now,
I'm starting to feel a little bit of anxiety cause as a picture get in my head
and pitch me that laser coming toward him. And you know, spoiler alert,
he doesn't actually get split by the laser. Yeah. Sorry.
But here's the thing.
Go and watch the movie now and see if you can get through that scene without
experience. Suspense.
And it really seems to say something very powerful and strong about how immerse
we can become in a narrative world.
Mama don't
[inaudible]
the thing is we do go in, Lee all fall into these stories. He says,
it's just the way we are built for hundreds of thousands of years. Our memories,
our friendships, our sense of family, our kinship.
We build our identities from stories,
stories that we tell and stories that we hear.
Um,
well, let's take a break coming up. Terror in the toilets,
python in the Potty, and more scary stories on this edition of Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. We will continue in a moment.
Support for NPR comes from NPR stations and Coffman,
the foundation of entrepreneurship, celebrating entrepreneurs,
creating a greener tomorrow on the
web@akauffman.org and the Annenberg Foundation advancing public wellbeing
through improved communication on the web.
Ed Annenberg foundation.org and the Ford Foundation,
a resource for innovative people and institutions worldwide on the
web@fordfounded.org. This is [inaudible] PR, National Public Radio
[inaudible].
It's good to get some like Jad Roberts, Radiolab and this.
I can
die a happy man. So that was perfect. So here we go.
This is radio lab. I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich and this
is the sound of 700 people who have come to bear witness to that
during our show today. We are in the Fitzgerald Theater at Saint Paul,
Minnesota talking about these strange phenomenon that is the war of the worlds.
You know, I, it's very great that everybody's here of course. But this,
there is one guy I really wish had been here. Who's that? The Ecuadorian guy.
Leonardo. Well, let's just, yeah, yeah, because he's the guy I want to ask.
Like what were you thinking? That's what I want. When he's dead,
he's dead. Yeah. Well, but how Orson Wells, I would say to him, what,
what were you thinking? I would say dead. They had, yeah.
How about the guy in Buffalo, buffalo? A missing retired?
I don't know. That's ask somebody.
So I found the guy who I think is definitely alive. I am Daniel Myrick,
Cole writer,
Co Director of the Blair witch project before making the Blair witch project and
my record a recording of the war of the worlds,
which he was pretty young at the time. He was a teenager.
I just thought it was brilliant. I absolutely,
the coolest thing and more than anything else,
he was impressed by the technique of the thing.
There's a couple of moments in particular where they cut to the kind of onsite
reporter, I'll return you to call fill upset drivers,
but it's almost like cut in a second or two early and you hear the reporters
saying, so are we on? Are we on it, ladies and gentlemen?
And then he goes into his indie character.
Here I am back with stonewall and it says little beats,
those little moments that really make it convincing.
I get this kind of guilty excitement when I, when I know how it affected people.
Myrick never forgot that sense of guilty excitement.
He was fascinated by the idea that scary stories get even scarier if you think
they're true. So years later, fresh out of film school,
he and his friend Eduardo Sanchez decided
to develop their own a well's like product. It's your basic scary which story?
Three a kids go into the woods. Okay, okay, okay, we're leaving right now.
They get lost.
They bumped into the witch and then they die or they think they die.
You never see them again.
But when you entered the theater to see the Blair witch project,
the first thing that you'd see on the screen are these two sentences.
It would read in October of 1994 three student filmmakers disappeared in the
woods near Burkittsville, Maryland while shooting a documentary. A year later,
their footage was found.
So the suggestion here is that what we see is not a movie with ag mind that you
were in a movie theater, right?
And you're paid $10 and have some popcorn. Yeah, yeah. But when you went,
when you went sat down,
what you saw was something called the found footage shot by three kids who have
gone missing. And so these kids, you're not sure,
but they might be real. Well,
we picked a subject matter that was difficult to disprove to the casual
observer. Martians invading from outer space is you turn the channel to the next
networking. If no one's reporting about it, it's pretty well assured.
It's probably fiction, but three missing students in the woods, you know,
that's something that is a little harder to disprove without a fair amount of
scrutiny. And it worked.
We were getting calls from police wondering where these three kids were and how
come they never heard of this case? You're kidding. Oh yeah.
I mean it was constant. Oh,
so people saw the whole thing and thought they saw something real still do.
I still get emails occasionally on what part of the story is real. You know,
is there still any phenomena out in Burkittsville and Dah, Dah, Dah,
all fiction and is all made up.
And I think it reinforces what I think Ed and I suspected that so much of us
wants to believe. Some people told Dan Myrick that after watching the suite,
campers go into the woods, they themselves would never go camping again.
And he thought that was fabulous. You love to go, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa,
whoa, Whoa, whoa. Why would you not want people to go camping?
I mean, well, no, honestly, why would you do that to people? I asked him. Well,
I think that's the goal of any filmmaker.
When you make a move and whether you want people to laugh or cry or be scared,
you're trying to affect people so viscerally and so emotionally that it has a
resonating effect on them long after they've seen your moving.
I mean that's why you're doing it. You know,
we're not making this movie to kind of scare people.
We were making the film to really scare people.
No regrets on people not wanting to go camping afterwards.
So the question is,
is that what Orson Welles was up to back in 1938 was he just trying to give
people a good old fashion show business scare,
make them scream way up in the balcony.
Cause remember at the time that is what he claimed,
that this was simply an entertainment. This is Austin, ladies and gentlemen
out of character to assure you that the war of the worlds has no further
significance. And as the holiday offering,
it was intended to be the mercury theater's own radio version of dressing up in
a sheet and jumping out of a Bush and saying boom.
16 years later, Orson wells changed the story.
Here he is on the BBC. The year is 1955
in fact, we weren't as innocent as we meant to be.
When we did the Martian broadcast,
we were fed up with the way in which everything that came over,
this new magic box, the radio was being swallowed.
So in a way our broadcast was an assault on the credibility of that machine.
We wanted people to understand that they shouldn't swallow everything that came
through the tap.
So here are two ways to think about the war of the worlds. One,
it was a smashing entertainment using every trick they could think of including
inventing some new ones to scare you.
Silly master storytelling or or,
and it was, we're trying to send you a warning,
don't trust everything you hear on the radio.
It's not always true to which one was it. You think?
Well, I asked the Professor Jason Lavilla me. Yeah,
you Jason Him. He's a radio historian at the University of Maryland.
He says that what wells understood was that a newscast is often two things at
once in a newscast. You hear something scary or disturbing sometimes,
but it's going to be told to you in a way that sues you,
meaning the authority of the voice, the newscasters,
steady voice coming through the radio.
It will calm you like President Roosevelt's famous fireside chat.
Hi Friend.
I want to prop for a few minutes with the people of the United States about
banking. He's so calm.
The charge as professor [inaudible],
when you study the rhetoric that Roosevelt used,
he really did convey two messages. One,
we're in terrible danger and two, I've got it covered.
And that is the sort of the, the authoritative voice coming out of the darkness.
This sort of invisible disembodied voice of the powerful man. Um,
the news anchor timber 22nd,
1940 and we'll see this with Moreau on the rooftops.
Britain standing on the roof during the blitz looking out over London,
straight in front of the, now you'll hear two sounds in just a moment
where they are.
He's giving us a story of an unfolding emergency,
I should think in a few minutes. There may be a bit of shrapnel around here,
but his mastery of the information,
his mastery of his own voice is bravery on the scene.
You may be able to hear the sound of guns off in the distance. Very thankfully,
like someone kicking a tub.
This was the beginning of the formatting of fear,
the formatting of crisis.
It's sort of a ritual where we're sort of evoking a terrible danger and then
somehow assuaging those fears through the performance of the news.
And so people go to the news not to be afraid but to be afraid.
And then to be reassured. Robert [inaudible] you file things for the news.
Yeah.
Do you buy this that a news reporter does these two things simultaneously,
gears and then reassures and then Scott, you never go, you know,
go cover the governor and say,
first I'm going to scare them and then I'm going to assuage them, you know,
when would do that? Why else would you talk that way? I mean not you. Oh,
but I mean the, the, the, the anchors will sometimes. Yeah.
Well, the the form him of the news is a,
because the guy is always there because he's an anchor.
That's what the word means.
It is a reassuring thing to see them night after night telling and telling,
but [inaudible] says that the real genius of the war of the worlds was that
wells put you into a newscast where you expect anchors to anchor and you expect
reporters to report and then he kills the reporter and the anchor and suddenly
you're left all by yourself in your own living room all alone.
Okay.
That is exactly right. The moment of the war of the worlds broadcast,
which still frankly terrifies me. It's this moment, right? Yeah.
Slice them head on.
[inaudible] the words that running every way,
cutting this boy dog by 20 yards by, right.
It's like that silence is terrifying. No anchor. No reporter,
no one too. We assure you. Okay,
but forgetting that for a moment.
What about his second lesson that he had to teach us the thing about don't
believe the radio. What about that? Did it work?
Well, professor at Lavilla says, if that is really what wells was trying to do,
if you believe that, well then he failed. Actually,
he worse than failed the war of the worlds. Not once, not twice.
We've shown you three broadcast tonight.
It was so good at grabbing an audience and sucking them in that the will's
formula,
you might call it the newscast that scares you enough to keep you listening,
has been adopted by of all folks. News
right now at 11 at night at shopping during the two at night of fear,
swarming over boardrooms, flooding, cities and towns, Muslim immigrants, jeans,
texting and driving.
It's a deadly mint terror in the toilet and sink holes and landslides.
Python in the cod,
a rabid baby go terrorists working at one of our airports.
So many newscast tease you with things that aren't quite true.
Terror in the toilet. Pythons in the potty. It may be,
there will be true snakes somewhere near a toilet tree facility of some kind,
but it probably wasn't the python and it probably wasn't your toilet,
but you don't know that. You want to hear that.
It belongs to Mrs. James C McGillicuddy of 2114 boday boulevard and not you.
So you,
you want to be reassured and so you listen and so you fall in.
And if Orson Welles retelling a Martian invasion story by HD wells that most
people already knew,
if he could grab us and then if they could do it again in Ecuador and then if
they can do it again in Buffalo, what does that tell you?
It tells you that we can't help ourselves even if the headline is slightly
preposterous, even if it's slightly scary, even if it's slightly
false, we will listen
[inaudible]
the fear of that these broadcasts generate now suck us in.
And you'd think that 70 years later we'd be more sophisticated and critical when
the local news cast or tells us that there's something we're feeding our
children that could kill them and they'll tell us after the news the way I still
listen.
I'm a media critic and I still wait through the commercials to see what is it
that I'm doing to kill my child. Even if it's really implausible,
your shoelaces will kill you after this beat method.
I somehow it gets me every time.
Yeah, and wells knew.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Radiolab is produced by [inaudible], met with Lulu Miller, Tony Field,
Rob Christensen and Ellen horn production support from Heather Radke,
Michael O'Ryan, Madis, Laura Vitale, Ariel Laskey, Soren Wheeler, Linda Evans,
the rest of Anderson San Anton, Molly bloom,
Bradley Campbell and [inaudible]. Special thanks to Chris Worthington,
Tom Keith, Zoe Keating, Tony Ball, Michael grand champ, Tom Campbell,
Joe Bevilacqua, Laura [inaudible], Oliver Conan, Nadia Reiman, Roberto Williams,
Lorraine Nadex, Scott Goldberg, Andy Lancet,
the motor Tomoto and Charles Michelin original music for this hour was provided
by cellist Zoe, Quito, Checkout Zoe keating.com you'll think of
before we close our show today,
I just want to remind you that anything that you heard today,
anything you've ever heard on radio lab can be
found@radiolab.org that is our address and while you're there I would encourage
you to email us radio lab@wynyc.org is their email address.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thank you so much for coming and thank you for listening.